dimanche soir lors du match psg om le
combat ne sait pas jouer seulement sur
le terrain du sport mais aussi celui de
l'affrontement entre les deux équipes la
tension est à son comble et les coûts
ont été légion sur le terrain ce qui se
passe sauf que voilà entre neymar côté
psg et alvaro gonzalez qui défendait les
couleurs de l'om
les mots auraient dépassé l'entendement
durant le match les barreaux aurait en
effet proféré des insultes racistes
envers neymar si durant le match étaient
les spectateurs n'ont pas pu assister à
cet échange la chaîne build for arabic
de son côté assure détenir les images
qui pourraient prouver les dires de
neymar de son côté le psg a décidé de
croire son joueur et de le soutenir
publiquement dans un communiqué le psg
soutient fermement neymar junior qui a
rapporté avoir été victime d'insultés
racistes par un joueur adverse
le club se tient à sa disposition pour
collaborer au déroulement des
investigations
neymar s'est quant à lui exprimé sur les
réseaux sociaux aurais-je dû ignorer ces
insultes aujourd'hui à tête reposée je
dis oui mais au moment du match nous
avons demandé de l'aide aux arbitres en
vain c'est le problème le mec est un con
j'ai aussi agi comme un conte en blé
sont impliqués là-dedans alors à faire
neymar pensez vous que l'on nous cache
quelque chose
est ce que c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
en coulisses ont l'air si daniel riolo
d'être avec nos journalistes
éditorialistes sur rmc/bfm nos confrères
à qu'on aime beaucoup d'ailleurs avec
qui on s'entend très bien et vous sortez
un livre chère football français des
vérités que le foot français refusent
d'entendre
peut-être que votre prochain livre ce
sera les vérité sur cette affaire parce
que c'est vrai que c'est le flou total
est ce que vous comprenez qu'en 2020
avec autant de caméras pour réaliser un
match on n'arrive pas à retrouver des
extraits je pense que la première
réalisation puisque c'était un peu le
match de rentrée pour le nouveau
diffuseur est un échec total
ils se sont complètement plantés avec 22
caméras tous les réalisateurs que j'ai
interrogés puisque depuis que ses
sorties
j'ai parlé avec pas mal de real quand
l'habitude de faire des gros matches ils
m'ont tous dit ça arrive à tout le monde
de raté des trucs à même des
réalisateurs qui ont raté des buts
sergent néanmoins on le vit très mal et
ça paraît complètement fou qu'avec 22
caméras a posteriori on n'arrive pas à
retrouver les images et surtout la faute
là peut-être la plus grave
comment confier ses réalisateurs que
j'interrogeais c'est de ne pas avoir mis
deux caméras isolé sur neymar
ça c'est un truc de fou parts égales qui
fait un match comme ça alors il est vrai
que le réalisateur a peu d'expérience
c'est la première fois qu'ils aient un
match aussi important
il avait plutôt l'habitude de faire des
matches plus petit avec 8 10 calmes
là il s'est retrouvé avec 22 aces qu'il
a été dépassé tout porte à croire qu'il
a effectivement été un petit peu dépassé
par les événements alors on a vu que
neymar avait faire un petit
rétropédalage
on va expliquer aux téléspectateurs
puisque cette affaire de racisme il
avait dit qu'il avait été traité voilà
et qu'il avait eut subi des insultes
racistes lors du match par alvaro
gonzalez et c'est vrai que là cette nuit
il a rétropédalé pourquoi vous avez nous
le dira j vous allez voir que la
sanction peut être énorme pour lui alors
il ya deux raisons la première raison
c'est que au brésil des médias ont
diffusé le numéro de téléphone d'alvaro
gonzalez qui a été menacé de mort donc
mais il m'a dit je dois calmer le jeu et
le petit et lui a dit ce sont même des
proches de neymar qui l'ont fait ouais
style qui lui auront kg né qui sait dans
l'entourage de neymar qu'on sait démerdé
pour donner le numéro d'alvaro un peu
partout ah oui alvaro a passé une nuit
le téléphone pourri dans tous les sens
d' insulte donc le joueur
le joueur s'était donc neymar aurait
donné le numéro voilà son numéro et donc
il a subi des varois étaient menacés
donc naïma et surtout le psg qui
cornaque neymar lui ont dit calme le jeu
par ailleurs la chaîne qui a des images
d'amis à la raison la chaîne qui a des
images de phase où on voit ce que dit
alvaro cbi ménat sébine au moyen-orient
qui a vertement au qatar qui a parfois à
qui on l'a on a les images absolument
regarder on a six images et vous à nous
dire j'ai qu'est ce qui dit à l'oreille
[Musique]
quoi
carrefour
[Musique]
à
cette histoire qui rebondit encore
langil oui alors il ya deux choses
bean a donc dit nous transmet les images
à la ligue et selon des sources que j'ai
dirons-nous du côté du psg mais je vais
mettre le conditionnel il ya deux choses
qui auraient été dit il ya un mange moi
les changements les testicules
voilà d'accord doit la mange mon niveau
je vois là je le note je vais voir si
j'ai un possible je vois les goules le
grotesque de la faire c'est qu'en ce
moment même où il ya trois personnes sur
le dossier ipg devant les écrans qui
sont en train de faire à ses scripts âge
je fais là alors donc il a personne qui
sont en train de faire alors mange moi
je crois qu'il est un peu quand il a dit
les boules voilà donc ça il n'y a pas de
racisme et là où il y en aurait eu en
espagnol c'est khayat et mono alors
qu'elle est mono pour traduire
vulgairement c'est ferme ta gueule
espèce de singe et là ce serait plus
rapide donc effectivement ils sont en
train de travailler là-dessus c'est là
dessus que le psg veut appuyer c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont dit à demain 17h pour
toute année alors que sur lloris neymar
c est la boutique et s'il n'est pas
prouvé alors neymar iris de la part d'al
waer ou un procès en diffamation parce
que tout l'om soutient le var au mois
d'août qui sera telle attaque en
diffamation
et sur le plan du jeu comme il a
bousculé les joueurs et sept matches de
suspension pour brutalité que non il y
aura pas jusque-là priori ils veulent
pas se fermer mais la rémission et puis
c'est le barème mais ce sera 3 max
d'accord alors daniel et vaut autour de
la table même ceux qui suivent cette
histoire parce que c'est au-delà du foot
est-ce que vous pensez que neymar a
menti
moi j'ai vu sa réaction je me disais
c'est pas possible on a des infos
francesca franchement cette histoire
elle est ahurissant version à une
récente ça fait deux jours alors on nous
parle de 22 caméras du côté de téléfoot
la chaîne
je ne sais pas combien du côté de binh
de binh sport et on ne trouve rien et on
peut aller chercher on va attendre quoi
les experts à miami
ncis c'est quoi en fait le dossier je
comprends pas non l'homme bien qu'il ait
trouvé quelque chose
je termine simplement mon propos si
rétropédale pour moi c'est simplement
qu'il n'est pas sûr de lui on le sait il
a été piqué dans son orgueil
ils perdent leurs deux premiers matches
il n'est pas très bon avait la stratégie
francesca c'est une stratégie du club
justement c'est une stratégie aussi de
neymar donc là on peut peut-être arrêter
de dire mais c'est d'abord la glace est
alors temps ça me semble avancer c'est
pourquoi le diffuseur d'abord à
travailler aussi mal sur ce match
pourquoi hier soir nous pendant notre
émission un présentateur vedette de la
chaîne appel en disant on a tout
décrypter il n'ya rien machin et tout
pourquoi le lendemain bindi nous on a et
pourquoi ils font un teasing toute la
journée
téléfoot de la chaîne pour des assez bon
à 19 ans on va vous révéler des choses
et qu'est ce qu'ils font ils mettent les
images d'un truc dont on a très peu
parlé mais qui est tout aussi grave
le crachat de neymar exception alors ça
là haut ça aussi est le crachat mais
vous qui contiendra rien pour d'émotion
on regarde comment les mecs l'insa on la
regarde et garder le crash des fous qui
nous permettent d'en savoir plus on
distingue clairement le mouvement visage
d'aurélie marié véreux alvaro gonzalez
autre axe de caméras celui ci a été
diffusé en direct dimanche quand vous
l'avez tous vu ça tombe sur les réseaux
sociaux peut distinguer un postillon en
direction d'avoir gonzalez mais
attention ne l'atteint pas ce qu'on voit
c'est di maria semble cracher ne semble
pas cracher sur leur honda days mais
crash en direction du défenseur espagnol
alors vous avez donc écrase factory et
c'est vrai que le jour le joueur
alors que le village de michael welch
pas les joueurs et crache compte match
ils n'arrêtent pas de se vider le nez
alors re des demandes une question
est-ce qu'alvaro a menti on le connaît
depuis est pas le tapis et là c'est
super mais il pas il va faire la bringue
avaient tous les blacks qui composent
l'équipe de l'olympique de marseille ça
ne rien dire c'est comme tommy john que
le mec qui va dire j'ai un ami juif
non mais si tu es raciste sur un système
- dieu pouvait tenir un truc là diane
est daniel et mais qui comprennent un
peu francesca village il peut qui se
rappelle ici c'est ce qui passe est
passé à la mi juin concerne aldemar
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à la mi juin
concert à amy jouer comme sernam neymar
va je crois qu'il a mangé des frites
d'alors j'aime bien qu'elle tenait à
géométrie variable tu vois là alors
voilà
neymar ah c'était ça pour ça portable
depuis tout à l'heure mais toute
médaille il à énergie solaire totale car
les mâts à la mi juin ont traité de [ __ ]
le corps de sa mère
ouais c'est vrai il y avait d'un côté
qui lie à dire on devrait lui mettre le
balai dans le cul
la personne n'irait les propos
homophobes en nous faisant tenir hier
sur le terrain le problème c'est
l'hommage d'alain n'a pas parlé par mme
dahlerup encore parler pendant un mois
de ça non non non non non et des écoutes
fille voilà où en bordel sur neymar
poutou où le fou furieux parce que
catoni le copain de ma mère si mpd on ne
voulait mettre comme balai dans le cul
non mais ce qui se voit c'est pas chez
moi raconte andré marcon est plus
violente que de dire à ces gens
c'est extrêmement violent que j'aie vu
les redire mais pourquoi le fou si
alvaro gonzalez a dit ça c'est
inadmissible je te le dis c'est
inadmissible a dit à bas juste attendre
pendant 24 heures on sera mais le
problème à la limite c'est même pas la
moralité des joueurs ou ce qu'ils ont
dit on va le savoir ce qu'ils ont dit
c'est que veut faire ce nouveau
diffuseur qui a foutu un milliard sur la
table pour avoir le foot il veut nous
raconter juste faire chier canal+ il
vous ne racontez une histoire où il veut
nous dire la vérité
il veut nous dire lundi soir on n'a rien
et le mardi quand les autres ont dit un
peu peut-être qu'on a quelque chose à
main d'un coup nous aussi on a fouillé
dans le carton va trouver quelque chose
quelle histoire il veut nous raconter
venait prendre pour des idiots oui elle
réellement nous montrer le foot alors là
c'est la question de téléspectateurs et
je perdais maladroite ou montré déjà
est-ce que neymar a menti ou pas dit la
vérité votre sentiment parce que là la
sphère rebondi et no3 de gesca mois pour
moi c'est une stratégie une stratégie a
marre parce qu'ils étaient piqués au vif
et donc vous commencez votre vous venez
pas parce qu'ils sont un père de la
finale et les deux champions du monde
aimerait sous le thème là là là vous dit
des bêtises alors il va accuser
quelqu'un de l'avoir traité d'avoir eu
des insultes racistes pour les parce
qu'il perd contre le marseille parce
qu'il a perdu contre lens ne m'a rien et
si je pense qu'il a menti je vous dis
oui de géraldine jeunesse montante
parole à daniel
ah oui alors c'est vrai que c'est commun
c'est le contraire de la maison aller
voir les deux qui a qu'elle qui parle et
daniel qui nous fait kiffer innoncent
alors oui moi je pense que neymar a dit
la vérité est que la chaîne télé foot tu
es pro marseillaise de cacher son pro
marseillais téléphone ils ont dit non à
ces gens là ils l'ont dit ben oui bien
sûr
[Applaudissements]
monsieur qui n'a ni paris ni la vie de
[Musique]
rené tu sais qui tu es tu sais qui est
le président de la chaîne c'est qui
ouais c'est jean michel rousset qui
était l'ancien président de l'om mais
c'est pas du tout pour ça qu'ils sont
passés alors tu vois pas vraiment là que
la brunie le papa tu veux parler on va
voir la cena faut que j'avais pas élevé
la vérité des mecs que le patron de
téléfoot à cissé l'ancien patron de l'om
et gilles une fois de plus il a des
bonnes infos s'est désolé est donné en
mai son âge il est tout le sens qu'elles
sont a dit dans une conférence de presse
on souhaite la victoire de l'om sur la
digue à la ligne il a dit je peux
ferrand le petit poucet qui bat
regardez 54% non à 46% en tout quatre
des merci daniel riolo d'abord est avec
vous chères cibles